grim was a show that defied the odds
during its six season run
while constantine and other supernatural
sagas came and went like a whisper in
the wind
grimm persevered due in no small part to
the series attracting a loyal fan base
who fell for its magical enchantments
and
dark some might say grim charms
nbc's folklore inspired procedural
follows nick burkhart
a portland detective and the descendant
of a long line of monster hunters called
grimms
a reference to the fairy tale scribes
the brothers grimm whose work inspired
the show
as the titular grim burkhardt has the
power to see through the human masks
worn by vesin
an ancient race of anthropomorphic
beasts with a wide array of magical
abilities
when vestin become irritated stressed or
aggressive
they undergo an accidental
transformation that reveals their true
form which is where burkhardt and his
team of monster hunters come in
i thought he was gonna kill me why
he's a grim that's what they do
what a grim although the series never
dazzled in the ratings it drew enough of
a committed following to carry on for
the better part of the decade
but to last like all good things in this
world the cult series had to come to an
end eventually so what prompted nbc to
drop the cancellation acts
surprisingly it came about in part
because the show's creators felt like
they didn't really have anything left to
say
while nbc ultimately made the decision
to cut grim from the schedule
show runners james coof and david
greenwalt told tv line that they felt
like they were running out of material
that would keep the show fresh
for that reason they weren't even really
upset by the cancellation in fact
the creators recalled feeling panic when
they thought season six would be renewed
for 22 episodes
breathing a sigh of relief when the
network only called for 13.
that limited order turned out to be a
blessing as the final season boasted a
rich
mythology-laden storyline that might not
have felt
nearly so satisfying if it had been
stretched out to a full 22 episode
season
fortunately for the fans and everyone
involved in the show's creation
grimm got to say goodbye on a high note
with a satisfying conclusion that
wrapped up the existing plot lines and
put a nice cherry on top of its story
series star david gentoli told tv line
that they were happy to get that chance
as many shows get cancelled without
having the opportunity to truly finish
their stories
in a way that is creatively satisfying
it might have helped that grim was part
of a larger zeitgeist
one part urban fantasy one part police
procedural
the show owed as much of a creative debt
to buffy the vampire slayer as it does
to law and order as a result
it felt like an oddball in nbc's lineup
but grimm had good company elsewhere
debuting in a season that was crowded
with fairy tale inspired content
while nbc was revving up the marketing
engine behind grim
abc was pushing its own buzzy new fairy
tale riff once upon a time
both shows defied their middling reviews
to live a
full life on their respective networks
heck after grim was cancelled once upon
a time carried on for another
year and unusually grim actually saw a
ratings bump in its final season
while season 5 hit a series low
averaging 5.97 million viewers
season 6 rose to 6.07 million and that
was apparently enough to convince nbc
that there might be more stories to ring
out of the concept yet
as a grim spin-off series with a female
lead was announced in 2018.
so far no further details have been
announced although some of grimm's cast
members confirmed in a youtube q a for
wizard world
that there have been some ongoing
discussions behind the scenes about
their characters returning
and with grim and once upon time now
both gone
it seems like there's a fairy tale
procedural sized hole in the network tv
ecosystem
just waiting to be filled here's hoping
they jump down that rabbit hole soon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you